Well, let's open our Bibles then to the Gospel of John.
The Gospel of John.
We are making our way through the I Am statements
of Jesus in the Gospel of John.
Now the I Am statements of Jesus,
as we said a couple of weeks ago,
are these statements that come from Jesus
that are throughout the Gospel of John
where he takes the foremost name of God
in the Old Testament, I am who I am.
And he applies that to himself.
He says, this is who I am.
And so you have these seven I Am statements of Jesus
throughout the Gospel where they're then connected
with a picture that tells us something
about who Jesus is.
He is the I Am.
And there's these different things we see about him.
So last week, Fred Johns came
and helpfully walked everyone through
where Jesus says I am the bread of life.
And then this morning, we are looking
at the next statement,
which is I am the light of the world.
So we're looking at John chapter eight and verse 12,
but then we're also going to continue on
and read the whole of John chapter nine.
Now we could not fit that on the worship guide
this morning if you're looking for it there.
So maybe if you've got a phone,
you could look it up there
or if you've got a Bible in front of you,
we're gonna make our way through the whole of that chapter.
So you have the I Am statements
in John chapter eight and verse 12.
And that comes to us in that kind
of succinct statement form.
And then in many ways it's then embodied
in this account that is given to us in chapter nine.
So we're gonna read both.
John chapter eight and verse 12.
Again, Jesus spoke to them saying,
I am the light of the world.
Whoever follows me will not walk in darkness
but will have the light of life.
John chapter nine.
As he passed by, he saw a man blind from birth.
And his disciples asked him, Rabbi,
who sinned?
This man or his parents that he was born blind?
Jesus answered, it was not that this man sinned
or his parents, but that the works of God
might be displayed in him.
We must work the works of him who sent me
while it is day, night is coming
when no one can work.
As long as I am in the world,
I am the light of the world.
Having said these things, he spit on the ground
and made mud with the saliva.
Then he anointed the man's eyes with the mud
and said to him, go wash in the pool of salom,
which means sense.
So he went and washed and came back seeing.
The neighbors and those who had seen him before
as a beggar were saying, is this not the man
who used to sit and beg?
Some said, it is he.
Others said, no, but he is like him.
He kept saying, I am the man.
So they said to him, then how were your eyes opened?
He answered, the man called Jesus made mud
and anointed my eyes and said to me,
go to salom and wash.
So I went and washed and received my sight.
They said to him, where is he?
He said, I do not know.
They brought to the Pharisees the man
who had formerly been blind.
Now it was a Sabbath day when Jesus made the mud
and opened his eyes.
So the Pharisees again asked him
how he had received his sight.
And he said to them, he put mud on my eyes
and I washed and I see.
Some of the Pharisees said, this man is not from God
for he does not keep the Sabbath.
But the others said, how can a man
who is a sinner do such signs?
There was a division among them.
So that they said again to the blind man,
what do you say about him?
Since he has opened your eyes,
he said he is a prophet.
The Jews did not believe that he had been blind
and had received his sight until they called
the parents of the man who had received his sight
and asked them, is this your son?
Who you say was born blind?
How then does he see?
His parents answered, we know that this is our son
and that he was born blind.
But how he sees, we do not know.
Nor do we know who opened his eyes.
Ask him, he is of age.
He will speak for himself.
His parents said these things because they feared the Jews.
For the Jews had already agreed
that if anyone should confess Jesus to be the Christ,
he was to be put out of the synagogue.
Therefore his parents said, he is of age, ask him.
For the second time they called the man
who had been blind and said to him,
give glory to God.
We know that this man is a sinner.
He answered, whether he is a sinner or not,
one thing I do, whether he is a sinner, I do not know.
One thing I do know, that though I was blind, now I see.
They said to him, what did he do to you?
How did he open your eyes?
He answered, I have told you already
and you would not listen.
Why do you want to hear it again?
Do you also want to become his disciples?
They reviled him saying, you are his disciple,
but we are disciples of Moses.
We know that God has spoken to Moses,
but as for this man, we do not know where he comes from.
The man answered, why this is an amazing thing.
You do not know where he comes from
and yet he opened my eyes.
We know that God does not listen to sinners,
but if anyone is a worshipper of God and does his will,
God listens to him.
Never since the world began has it been heard
that anyone opened the eyes of a man born blind.
If this man were not from God, he could do nothing.
They answered him, you were born in utter sin
and would you teach us?
And they cast him out.
Jesus heard that they had cast him out
and having found him, he said,
do you believe in the Son of Man?
He answered, who is he, sir?
That I may believe in him.
Jesus said to him, you have seen him
and it is he who is speaking to you.
He said, Lord, I believe and he worshiped him.
Jesus said, for judgment I came into this world
that those who do not see may see
and those who see may become blind.
Some of the Pharisees near him heard these things
and said to him, are we also blind?
And Jesus said to them, if you were blind,
you would have no guilt.
But now that you say, we see your guilt remains.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord, you are the God who said,
let light shine out of darkness.
Lord, I pray that by your light
you would shine into our hearts
that we may see the light of the knowledge
of the glory of God in the face of Jesus.
Lord, I pray that you would help us to trust
and to follow him.
What's in his name we pray, amen.
When I was a kid, I wasn't a big fan of school
but I was a big fan of field trips
and one of my favorite field trips to go on
was to DeSoto Caverns State Park.
I don't know if any of you have been there before.
You go to the big cave and I remember enjoying
all the things that you could see in the cave
but I also enjoyed a part of the tour
where they would actually turn all the lights off
in the cave, because you've not experienced darkness
until you've experienced darkness in a cave.
It was absolutely terrifying.
Thankfully they sat all the kids down
and we weren't kind of wandering around,
you know, knocking into things.
But it was absolutely pitch black
and they turned the lights back on.
But there are lots of cave rescue stories out there
that start with, you know, everything was fine
until the battery went out on the flashlight
and people didn't think to bring a spare set of batteries
or a spare flashlight.
You could read stories.
I read stories from a cave rescuer
who said like in a very short span of time
he rescued two different boys from two different caves
who were within 100 yards of the mouth of the cave
where they'd gone in but their lights had gone out
and they absolutely could not find their way
around the cave and they had completely lost hope
and were just staying in place right where they were
before they were rescued.
So light was absolutely essential and they didn't have it.
Can you imagine how frightening that would have been
or the kind of hope that you'd be hit with,
the joy that would come over you
when you see a light coming into the cave?
Well here in our passage and in this I am,
Jesus comes into this world of darkness
as the light of the world and he speaks up
and he says I am the light of the world.
Whoever follows me will not walk in darkness
but will have the light of life.
So in the start world, Jesus is shining as this light.
So for the next few moments, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna look at the statement
and we're gonna see what Jesus means
when he declares that he is the light of the world
and then we're gonna see what he's telling us
about what it means to be his disciple.
Because you have that in John chapter eight and verse 12,
you see he's telling us who he is
and what it means to follow him as a disciple,
what it means to walk in his light.
So let's see Jesus declaration here.
So what is Jesus saying when he's saying
he is the light of the world?
Now it'd be hard to overstate the importance of light.
If Jesus is claiming to be light, I mean,
when you think about how essential light is for life,
it's amazing.
So we need light for sight.
So light enables us to see.
So all the colors you see around you, like this morning,
are the result of reflected light.
Without light, we could not see beauty.
It's essential to perceive reality.
But also light is essential not just for sight,
but for life.
If you wanna do something frightening, Google,
what would happen if the sun stopped shining?
If the sun stopped shining in less than nine minutes,
Earth would be in total darkness, right?
It would take that long because of the light
traveling to us.
Then shortly thereafter, the temperatures would start
to drop and then plants would start to die,
leaving us not only without food, but without oxygen.
And so if there is no light, there is no life.
So light is literally the difference between life
and death.
So Jesus light, he's talking about here,
is a light that gives us life.
So those who have his light have life.
It is the light of life.
It's the difference between life and death,
but also his light enables us to perceive reality
and to navigate our way through life.
It is by his light that we truly see.
But Jesus' statement here isn't just a kind of
an illustration chosen at random
to tell us something about himself.
It is, there's a particular context that he says this
that helps us to understand this claim.
Really, we're looking at chapter seven
all the way through chapter nine here
with what Jesus is claiming when he claims
to be the light of the world.
So what's the context?
It's the feast of booths or the feast of tabernacles.
I don't know if you've been thinking a lot
about the feasts of the Old Testament this week.
If you need to be reminded of what they're about,
well, let me get us up to speed
on not all the Old Testament festivals,
but this one.
So this is a festival week, week long.
It's commemorating the wilderness wanderings
where God had delivered his people from slavery in Egypt
and was guiding them for 40 years through the wilderness
as they made their way to the promised land.
And during that time, during the wilderness wanderings,
the Israelites would camp in tents.
And so this festival was then separated,
or not separated, celebrated by camping.
So people would make their way from all over
and they would set up these kind of like
little temporary shelters in Jerusalem
and they'd have a week long kind of camping thing
together in this kind of like camping festival.
I don't know, you might think of like Woodstock
or Burning Man or just without the drugs or all the other.
It's don't think about that.
Think about a family camping trip.
It's like a family camping trip.
The festival of tabernacles, the feast of booths.
And like any camping trip, light was absolutely essential.
It was an essential part of the wilderness wanderings
for sure.
When you look back at the wilderness wanderings,
you see light all over the place.
So as God is present among his people
and guiding his people, he is present among them
and guided them with a pillar of cloud by day
and a pillar of fire by night.
So his light is guiding them through the wilderness.
It was during that time that God gave them
his law on Mount Sinai and where God is giving the law.
There's this cloud that covers Mount Sinai
and God makes himself known in fire that we're told
as he is giving his law there on the mountains.
You have light on the top of the mountain
as God is giving guidance through his word.
It's interesting to note that the Hebrew word for light
is or.
And then the first five books of the Bible,
the books of the law are called the Torah.
See a relationship between those two?
So or Torah.
So right in the middle of the Torah,
these first five books of the Bible
is this kind of play on words here.
You have God is guiding us by the light of his word.
So you then have like Psalm 119, 105,
which says your word is a lamp into my feet
and a light unto my path.
So the God who guided his people through the wilderness
also guides his people by his word
and all of that is described as light.
Also during the Wondrings,
God dwelt among his people in this tent
called the Tabernacle.
The Tabernacle is to be lit continually
by a golden lamp stand.
But fast forward to Jesus Day
as they're celebrating the Feast of Booth's.
One of the main ways this feast was celebrated
and this is something that kind of was added later on
that was happening during Jesus Day
is they would light these four candelabras.
And don't think of like a candelabra
that you'd have like on your dinner table
or something like that.
These were huge.
I mean think like lighting the Olympic torch
where I see had these four ginormous candles
that were put in the temple courts
and they would light them up.
And when they would light them,
light would flood the city.
And you can read in the Mishnah
which is a recording of these Jewish traditions
that when the light would then flood the city
with the candles there'd be singing
and there would be dancing.
People would be praising the God who saved his people,
who dwelt among his people in the wilderness.
The God who guides his people in the path of life.
So you've got this blazing light there.
And we're told in this passage
that when Jesus says what he says
it is as this festival is drawing to a close.
But imagine the setting.
Jesus we're even told that he is in the temple courts
where these lights had been.
And he stands up and says,
I am the light of the world.
Whoever follows me will not walk in darkness
but will have the light of life.
I would have been such a shocking statement.
Do you see what he's saying?
He's saying this God that you are celebrating, that's me.
All of this is pointing to me.
Yes, it's pointing back to him and what he did in the past
but he's pointing to me now.
I am the radiance of his glory,
the embodiment of his presence.
I am the one who guides you on the path of life
to the land of promise.
So this festival was ultimately pointing to him.
It was a shadow but he is the light.
So when Jesus is saying he's the light
he's not just saying like he's another like luminary,
like a philosopher or a religious guru
or something like that.
He is saying that he is God himself.
He is the light of the world.
It's a claim to deity.
So you've got the fulfillment of this festival
but you've also got the fulfillment of a promise.
In the book of Isaiah chapter two verse five
you see that God's people there
are called to walk in his light.
But you also see that they were called
to be a light to the nations.
That what God was doing there was for the whole world
that was coming a day when the nations
would come to know the Lord and walk in his ways.
And later on in Isaiah God says
that there's a section called the servant songs.
You've got these different songs talking about
the servant or the Messiah that's coming into the world.
And one of the things that it says
that's going to be true about this servant
the Messiah that God is going to send.
You see this in Isaiah 42 6 and 49 6.
He says he's coming to be a light to the nations.
That my salvation may reach to the ends of the earth.
So God is a God of radiant glory
and he saves his people
but he is also going to save bring his salvation
to the nations and the way he's going to bring
that salvation is by sending the light of the world.
When Jesus says I am the light of the world
he's also saying I'm fulfilling that promise.
So it's like what John said in the prologue
in him was life and the life was the light of man.
He is the very glory of God tabernacle among us.
John chapter one verse 14.
So he's bringing salvation.
So if God's word is revealing his light
Jesus is that word.
So what is the word that makes God's salvation known
in the world?
What's the word of the gospel?
It's the message of the gospel.
It's the message that Jesus was bringing salvation
through his, yes his sinless life
but also his sacrificial death on the cross
and his resurrection.
Jesus went to the cross.
As he was dying, darkness were told
covered the face of the land.
And as he's there, our sin is laid upon him.
He there dies the death that we deserve for our sin.
Of course his body is then taken from the cross
and laid in a dark tomb which is sealed by a heavy stone.
We're also given the detail that three days later
it was very early in the morning
just after the sun rose
that the tomb was flooded with light
as the people came to see
that Jesus had risen from the dead.
Yes the darkness was deep
but it could not overcome the greatness of his light.
Risen Christ is the one who gives sight.
He gives life.
He calls us to receive the life
that only he can give.
He's the light who brings salvation to the world
and to us here this morning.
So that's what Jesus tells us about who he is.
But he's the light,
the one who brings salvation to the world.
But what does it mean to be his disciples?
What does it mean to follow him?
Who says whoever follows me,
this is chapter eight and verse 12 again,
will not walk in darkness
but will have the light of life.
Last weekend we were on a family camping trip
and it made me think of a few years ago
when we went to the same place,
this is a Gulf State Park
and while we were there
it was the sun had already gone down
so it was getting nighttime
and one of the kids was in the hammock
and while they were in the hammock
all of a sudden we heard some rustling in the leaves
and they heard it a bit louder beside them
and they looked down and they said,
oh it's an armadillo.
So there was an armadillo there
and we were like, okay, it's an armadillo.
Just don't move, just stay there, it's an armadillo.
And so the armadillo then made its way
through a couple more campsites
before people finally had the sense
to put a bunch of flashlights on it
and somehow between our campsite and the other
the armadillo had become an alligator
and all the lights were shining on it,
the brothers were shouting, alligator, alligator.
And so needless to say we learned our lesson that week
and the lesson wasn't that you don't camp
near shark infested waters, not shark infested,
alligator that would be bad too,
alligator infested waters,
but rather when you're camping,
especially in a place like that,
you always have light with you
so you can see where you're stepping,
what is around you, it's important.
So we see here that Jesus' disciples
are those who receive the light that he gives.
When we receive his light,
it then changes the way we navigate life
because in his light we see yes who he is
but we also see life as it really is.
It changes the way we see everything else around us.
It shows us the dangers as well as the good.
It's recalled to walk in his light.
So Jesus is not only the light, he gives light
and his disciples are those who have received his light
and the evidence that they have received his light
or have received the eternal life that comes through him
is that they learn to walk in his light.
So this, as I mentioned earlier,
is embodied and illustrated by what we read about
in chapter nine, it's the story of the healing
of the man who was born blind.
And in that story, Jesus deals with two forms of blindness.
And by the way, just to point out the obvious,
when we're talking about blindness in sight,
you can see how that's analogous to darkness and light
or what you're going from darkness to light
when you're healed of blindness.
And Jesus here is dealing with two forms of blindness.
He's dealing with physical blindness and spiritual blindness.
And what he does with physical blindness
points to the greater spiritual reality.
All right, so he heals the man's physical blindness,
first of all.
There's so much here.
There's 41 verses in John chapter nine.
I'd love to just walk through verse by verse today,
but we're just gonna just hit the highlights.
So Jesus sees this man who was born blind.
And his disciples ask him a question.
Remember the question that said, well, who sinned?
Was it this man or his parents?
Well, was it his sin?
Is that the reason he was born blind?
Or was it his parents sinned
that caused him to be born blind?
The answer was it was neither.
In fact, they were making a kind of categorical error.
And Jesus points this error out to them.
And this is a kind of a side note here,
but just to, it's good for us to get to grips with this.
Their error is assuming that when bad things happen to people,
it must be because of a specific thing that they did wrong.
Right, that there's a kind of one for one there.
So like if this bad thing's happening to you,
you've gotten sick or whatever,
you must have a specific sin that has caused this.
Now it is true in a general sense
that the brokenness that has come into the world
and the hardship, the suffering that we experience
is ultimately because of sin.
God created a perfect world and sin into the world
and that's the way we have the suffering and brokenness
in front of us.
But it is wrong to assume that a specific hardship
is always punishment for a specific sin.
That was the error of Job's friends
if you read the book of Job.
And it is the error of the disciples here
because Jesus makes it clear.
It is not because of any of his specific sins.
So as a side note, don't make the same mistake
either with yourself or maybe with a counsel
you give to others.
Jesus says, no, he is blind actually.
So that, this is verse three,
so that the works of God might be displayed in him.
God has got a unique work that he is going to do
through his life.
He's gonna display his glory.
So how does Jesus do it?
I don't know if anybody saw this coming.
He spat on the ground.
He then went down to the ground.
He started making some mud with the ground
and he takes that mud and he sticks it on the man's eyes
and he calls him to go and wash.
And you read this and you think,
what in the world is he doing?
I know I was reading through this, I was thinking,
I don't know what is going on here?
What, why is he using this mud?
And you kind of read different ideas
people have about it.
And some people say, well,
well it shows us that Jesus uses means.
Like if he uses mud, he can use you
and that kind of thing.
And I don't know, that's true.
Or maybe he was just trying to agitate the Pharisees.
You see that happen a bit later on,
you know, because he's working on the Sabbath day
and that's what makes them mad.
And that could be the case.
But remember, there's something going on here in John.
John is, there's a kind of a creation motif, if you will.
So John is showing that Jesus is the I am.
He is the Creator.
The book of John begins in the beginning.
Just like Genesis.
You've got these seven statements, these seven signs,
just like the week of creation
pointing to Jesus as the Creator,
the one who's come to bring about a new creation
to give us new life.
When you read and you're thinking about this
in the context of that overarching theme in John,
you think about, well, when God created man,
where did he begin?
He began with the dust of the ground.
This man here is about to be given a new life.
He's been blind from birth.
He's about to see and his life's gonna be completely different
from here on out.
And that begins the Creator reaching down
into the dust of the ground.
And you see that this one who is,
there's another play on words here,
the one who has been sent by God
now sends this man to a pool called sent.
All this is pointing like,
Jesus really is this one who has been sent by God.
And when the blind man passes through the waters,
he goes from blindness to sight,
he goes from darkness to light,
and he steps out with a kind of newness of life.
So this is pointing to what Jesus came to bring about.
He came that we might have new life, eternal life in him,
his healing of this physical blindness,
showing him to be the one who heals spiritual blindness.
Let's think about spiritual blindness a bit more.
It's not just me kind of making the connection here,
by the way, you have chapter nine ending
with Jesus making an explicit statement
that is summarizing the spiritual reality
that's being portrayed by the events
that have just taken place.
So in verse 39, he says,
for judgment I came into this world
that those who do not see may see
and that those who see may become blind.
Then Jesus says at the end,
but now that you say, saying this to the Pharisees,
we see your guilt remains.
So asking, are we blind?
And you say, well, yes,
you're blind in your sinful state.
So what is spiritual blindness then?
Well, spiritual blindness,
but simply as the inability
to truly perceive spiritual reality.
Reminded this week of Plato's allegory of the cave.
I don't know if you've ever come across that.
He talked about life as being like these three men
being chained up in this cave
and they're looking at this wall
and there's a fire behind them
and all they see are these shadows on the wall.
And as far as they know,
these shadows are the only kind of reality that exists.
This is all that they have experienced.
And they're unaware of anything else outside the cave.
One day one of these men are freed.
Their shackles are taken off
and they make their way outside the cave.
And all of a sudden, the world is so expansive.
It's flooded with light.
All these things they had no idea existed.
Now they can see it's been there all along,
but they haven't seen it.
This is real.
This is true.
There was a sense in which like,
yes, those shadows on the wall were true,
but they weren't all that there was.
There was a transcendent reality
beyond what the eyes could see.
And so as the kind of story goes,
he goes back into the cave
and tries to convince these other guys
who are chained up of what they're missing out on.
And they think he's the crazy one.
Because all they've experienced
are these shadows on the wall
and they think he's the one who's lost it
as he describes the light
and beauty that he has seen outside the cave.
And some ways this parable kind of,
this story kind of almost works as a parable
for what we see about spiritual blindness here.
You've got people kind of looking at one layer
of reality in the world.
And it is real, all right?
So this is real, but there is more going on.
There's a spiritual reality that is just as true
as the physical reality that we can see in front of us.
And that spiritual transcendent reality
can be known and experienced.
And how can it be known and experienced
when we are set free by Jesus,
brought into his light?
There's so many people who only see the shadow
and think that's all that there is.
They just don't understand.
They don't perceive.
They're in the dark.
They're spiritually blind.
You see this kind of lack of perception of reality
and how people respond when the blind man is healed here.
We read, first of all, that the neighbors,
they just cannot believe that this has happened.
Like, I know you look like the guy,
but you can't be the guy.
And why can't he be the guy?
Because, well, blind people don't see.
Like, it just doesn't work.
So they don't believe it.
And you've got the Pharisees,
like it's not just that they don't believe it.
They can't believe it.
This cannot be true.
And Jesus definitely can't be sent by God.
No matter how much the evidence points in that direction,
they cannot believe it.
So their lack of perception or understanding shows
that they are blind spiritually.
You've got this conversation with them
and the blind man where he's saying like,
why are you asking me again?
Like, are you wanting to become one of his disciples?
I mean, it's almost comical the way this plays out here.
And their response just shows their blindness,
their pride.
It's obvious.
They're so offended.
They say you were born in utter sin
and you would teach us.
What do you have to teach us?
Kick him out of the synagogue.
So their reaction shows,
not only their inability to perceive spiritual reality,
but their unwillingness too.
Not just that they're not able,
they're not willing.
They don't want it.
They don't want to acknowledge
who Jesus truly is.
Because if they acknowledge
that this is who Jesus truly is,
then they would have to humble themselves.
They'd have to say that they got it wrong.
They would have to be honest about their sin.
Here these guys are with all their titles,
their degrees or all the respect
that they have in the community.
They would have to admit that this guy,
who was blind,
who was beneath them, so to speak,
from their perspective,
they'd have to admit that he was right
and they were wrong.
They don't want that at all.
This is what Jesus said about light
in John chapter three, verses 19 and 20.
He said, this is the judgment
that light has come into the world
and the people loved darkness
rather than the lights,
because their works for evil.
For everyone who does wicked things
hates the light and does not come to the light
lest his works should be exposed.
That's the thing about the light of God.
It exposes.
It shows us for who we truly are.
It reveals what is hidden in the darkness.
We all do prefer to keep our sin hidden away.
Like we love the darkness rather than light
because we want to keep those things hidden.
God's light reveals our ignorance,
sinfulness, or pride.
That light shines.
We've got an option.
Are we gonna run to the shadows?
Are we gonna run to Jesus?
Good news is then the light of Christ
shows us who he is
and what he has done for us
that we might be forgiven and reconciled to God.
Even today, like as we're thinking about
the light of God shining us
as we're seeing this in his word,
are we willing to be honest about our sinfulness
to confess that before God?
Are we gonna hide in the shadows?
Are we gonna stay in the dark?
Are we gonna run to the light of Christ
to know the forgiveness and cleansing
that comes through him?
Well, when we come to know Christ,
like the Pharisees who kicked this man
out of the synagogue,
we too will be rejected in the world.
There's hardship that comes with following Christ.
But the wonderful news is,
I like this man, Jesus will meet us there.
And when we meet Jesus there,
we'll find that he is better than anything
that we've left behind.
You know, there are other people like his parents.
It says that they didn't want to speak about Jesus
because they feared that they would be kicked
out of the synagogue
and that this man is willing to be open.
In his openness, Jesus beats him there.
So whatever it is that we keep us from Jesus,
he is far better than what we have in him is worth it.
So what's the solution for spiritual blindness?
Believing in Jesus, putting our faith in him
and saying, yes, you are the light of the world.
I'm gonna put my trust in you.
When Jesus met the man outside the synagogue,
he told him that he is the Son of Man, the Messiah,
the promised King.
And we're told that the man who was blind believed him
and he worshiped him.
And so now this man has true sight.
He has his physical sight.
He also has spiritual sight as well through faith in Christ.
This is a picture of eternal life
that we can have through faith in Jesus.
So we believe in Jesus, but also when we believe in him,
we then reflect his light in the world.
So how does the light of Jesus bring salvation
to the ends of the earth?
How does that light get there?
It is through us.
It is when those who have seen the light,
again walking in his light in public,
and shine his light.
Bear witness to his light by speaking of Jesus.
You see this in John 12, 36.
It says, believe in the light while you have the light
so that you may become children of light.
So his light should be reflected
in the lives of his people.
Whoever follows me, this is evidence
of true discipleship, will not walk in darkness,
but will have the light of life,
his light reflected in us.
And Matthew's Gospel records Jesus saying something
that is really just astounding, mind-blowing,
especially given what we've seen about Jesus
being the light of the world.
Matthew 5, 14, and 16, he's a said,
who is disciples, you are the light of the world.
Amazing.
He says, let your light so shine before others
so that they may see your good works
and give glory to your Father who is in heaven.
That's not to say we are gods or anything like that,
but it's to say that in Jesus we have a new identity.
We are children of light who reflect his light
in the world around us that his salvation
may reach to the ends of the earth.
Let's pray together.
Where we want to praise you,
that Jesus' light was not concealed.
That he came into this world and boldly declared,
I am the light of the world.
Where we thank you that the light of the message
of his salvation has reached to us.
Lord, I pray that you would help us all to live
in his light that we would be ready
and willing to confess our sinfulness.
Then we would run to Jesus and know the sight
and life that is found in knowing him.
So we'll pray that you'd help us to trust in you
as our light, as our life.
We'll pray that you'd help us to walk in your light.
Pray that you would through us make the light of Christ
known in the world around us.
That it may glorify you.
In Jesus' name, amen.